our first guest this morning is someone
who was already thrown her hat in the
race the former Work and Pensions
Secretary grew up in Liverpool but now
represents the people of Tatton she
campaigned for brexit and is now arguing
that it's time to actively embrace
leaving without a withdrawal agreement
estimate very first declared her
intention to run on this show and now
she's back to tell us more about why she
wants to be Prime Minister thank you
very much for being with us this morning
there's certainly lots of brexit
supporting MPs already in the race so
why should people vote for you well
there's a couple of things first of all
we've got to deliver brexit which I've
always said and I've been very straight
talking about that and now the 31st of
October is the key date and we're coming
out then and if that means without a
deal then that's what it means we've got
to come out then then we've got to build
trust with the public something that we
have absolutely broken down and trust
means not just words it means actions
and deeds and people can see that you're
following through and then we need
honesty for a change this was a polar
debate in or out Teresa may had tried to
please both sides by which she pleased
neither and now we've got to say and be
fair we've got to choose a side the
fairest side will be that which one the
Democratic votes the biggest ever and
that is to leave and at the same time
we've got to do some radical changes
immediately and that is which I've
already said we've got to put more money
into schools we've got to put more money
into police and that will come because
obviously we've got to live within our
means from the extra amount that has
gone in year after year to foreign aid
gone up by nearly 66% when other budgets
have been cut and now we're going to
have to say you know what we'll go to
leave it at high levels high levels at
which it was at however we've now got to
look after people at home particularly
safety on the streets particularly in
school and transport in the NHS and that
is the vision we've got to set out and
unite the country and our party ok so
you're happy to raise taxes and that's a
lot of priority no I've never said I'd
be raising taxes how to it none day you
can't find
all from international heads can you
well what happened what we've seen from
2010 to 2017
the foreign aid budget went up from 8
billion to now 14 billion which leaves
us with examining them there's like
enough money well for where we start
which is what I do straight away an
extra 4 billion for schools I believe in
social mobility and the building blocks
for success is through a good education
and then we need an extra 3 billion for
police because we need to make sure that
we've got a safe environment I'm
standing on a blue collar conservative
platform and that is for regular people
who do you know what pay into the system
work hard but want to know they get
something back from the government so is
that really your differential if you
like if you look at news of the other
people in the race has a couple of old
Etonians as a former child has public
school boy when you were and of course
race in foster care is that is that
where it's more coming from well there's
other things too of course the Tories
now have got to reach out beyond their
base we've got to make sure that we're
talking to all of the regions and to the
north of the country now it's brilliant
that the South doing that is doing young
yes well we could be doing it far more
we've talked about the north and how
powerhouse we've now got to make sure
that we deliver it and as a fiercely
proud northern I'd be doing that but
it's for the rest of the country because
it's great that the South is doing well
and that London's doing well that's
great but it's like having a plane with
two engines only one is working we need
both engines to work and then our
country can soar
that's what we've got to do and I would
be doing that ok I'm keen to talk a bit
about brexit you're just saying there
that whatever happens you would like to
see the UK leaving the EU at the end of
October a deal or no deal so are you
going to try and renegotiate or are you
actually just going to move to a no deal
position what we've got to do
straightaway actually is start preparing
a lot of the preparations have been done
so you're quite right that date is now
fixed it's not that I'd like to come out
on that date or I don't want to that
date is fixed well you put on this
essentially well we won't be asking for
any more extensions that's part of the
corrosive uncertainty that individuals
business and the country don't want so
that date is fixed so of course we have
to say we need to make sure that we're
ready to
leave on that date now if the EU wants
to come back to us the door is open if
they want to have a better deal that's
fine we've always wanted a free trade
agreement but what we've got to do is
not waste time time is limited we have
to make sure that we are ready so to
leave so you wouldn't approach the EU
that with with a different negotiating
strategy you'd wait to see what they
offer and if they don't offer anything
then you'd move to well they've said
quite clearly that they don't want to
they've said that withdrawal agreements
is the only one they want now
parliament has made quite clear that
they don't want that withdrawal
agreements biggest ever historical
losses only have three times not for the
first not once not twice and I resigned
from government on it it is a bad deal
we're now in a different position and
that withdrawal Agreement boat has
sailed so what we've got to do the EU
doesn't want to move the UK therefore
has to be prepared to leave and as we
know and I'm a unionist as we know with
no deal actually there is no backstop so
this is the best thing we can do prepare
for No Deal well let's talk about that
the backstop of course is absolutely key
if you were going to leave with no deal
would you be happy to say of order in
Ireland because that is the reality
isn't it no because we can do an
invisible border so why is it a 31st yes
how is that gonna work because the
contest isn't going to finish till the
end of July then you're in summer recess
well if there's no real note if we will
get real if there is no deal we know
that the EU ain't going to put up a
border we know that Island isn't going
to put up a border there will be no hard
border so we have to make sure that
people understand them well you've said
that they will be a border
there'll be an invisible border and how
let me explain this whilst it whilst it
will be new the technology already
exists to be able to put that in place
and that now is what we need to make
sure that we do and when you're talking
about checks the admin customs
declaration is on line and when you talk
about a border there's already a border
for currency in v80 so we know the
technology exists we've already been
having meetings
in the house on what is possible there
so we know we can go forward and have
the invisible border but we're won't be
in Boise by the 31st of October that's
the key isn't it yeah that's when we are
going to be ready for and that's when it
needs to be ready for and we need to say
to people this is when we're coming out
as I say the EU have already said they
will not be putting up a border we know
that Island have said that so now we
need to make sure that that is what
happens no border okay no hard border
okay um how do you think Therese may of
course step down resigned announced her
resignation that will be coming in
twelve days time how do you think she'll
be remembered she'll be remembered for
somebody who was very dutiful she'll be
remembered for somebody who picked up
that leadership at a time when there was
no leadership David Cameron walked away
and the other contenders for the job and
fell by the wayside so she in a dutiful
manner took that the lead of the country
and went forward when you um left the
government there was a lot of talk
wasn't there about you becoming
emotional in that last Cavalier meeting
you said that you didn't cry do you did
it how did you feel when you read all
those articles analyzing Tories amazed
tears this one do you think we talk
about our female politicians in
different way well well the difference
was and there wasn't any tears with me
but the where tears with tourism a and I
think it showed her as a a very honest
woman at that moment it was emotional
for her she had done what she thought
was the best she had tried to do keeping
everybody on board and that's where I
think the honesty now has got to come in
you do have to choose a side she'd
always said in a mansion house speech
echo and have a half in half but just
like that that you had to work choose
leave but I think she was very honest
with herself at that moment Theresa May
once said that the naughtiest thing
she'd ever done was running for wheat
fields what's the naughtiest thing
you've ever done
oh that's for me to know and you
probably not